so um thank you so much for the
invitation
um to to speak today i'm sorry that i
can't be there
mostly because you guys have great
weather but because it would be great to
get on an airplane and go someplace
um i've been i've been holed up uh for a
long time like everybody else but super
hold up i have autoimmune issues so i've
been super shielded
for since uh since march so here i am i
get to see people and i get to see you
um so i want to talk about keeping
digital products safe as as um
folks have already mentioned i'm a
management consultant so i'm probably
really different than a lot of you in
the room
i think my the best street cred that i
have is that i'm around you
all the time when i do the work of
digital governance and i'll talk a
little bit about what that is um as we
push into the
into the presentation i'm around you and
i see you
so i think of myself as an advocate for
makers an advocate for technologists
um so i'm going to say this a million
times over the course of this uh
you know 40 45 minute talk which is this
is not about bashing people for making
things
that aren't absolutely perfect um
sometimes it seems like this problem
that we have online and
all the churn and crazy that's happening
and the impact
of these new technologies that we've
been using for the last 20 25 years
is that it's so big that we can't really
do anything about it so my goal is to
really talk about the problem
of what's happening online talk about
how we get into
environments that are unsafe in general
and then apply that to digital
define digital safety and then towards
the end just talk
some about what it means to keep things
safe
and about doing work where you are so if
there's anything i'm going to say it at
the end
there's anything that i really want
everyone to hear
in this conversation is that you know
you can't boil the ocean
but everyone can do something to keep
things safer where they are
in the present moment right now so um
that's what i'm going to talk about
there's a lot of rich conversations
going about about ethics and
and a lot of political conversations i
hear them and i honor them
but i really really like this frame of
safety because i think it
objectifies it a little bit makes it a
little bit just passionate and it's
actually a problem that you can work
so that's where i'm going to be for most
of the time and i'm looking forward to
any questions criticisms anything that
you have to say about that
and mostly i hope that you just get some
value out of this
so i'm going to tell you a couple
stories just because i really like
stories
um i'm writing a murder mystery set in
silicon valley right now which is really
fun
this kind of runs into like who would
you not want to kill but anyhow
there's a lot of fun things around that
but anyhow so i really like stories a
lot so here this is the story of
unfortunately the story of mary ward so
in 1869
mary ward was an irish naturalist and an
author and she's riding in
with her family her cousins in this
steam-powered automobile it was a
prototype automobile
and she's thrown from the vehicle as
it's going around the bend unfortunately
she falls into the path of the vehicle
her neck's broken and she dies instantly
and so the reason why i'm bringing out
this story is not to be gory
but it was the first recorded automobile
fatality
right so obviously for us right now
sitting where we are in 2020
that sort of three-point seat belt like
the kind invented by um
from volvo in the 1950s and that patent
was sort of
donated to industry that would have
saved her life and
it really seems like those types of
safety innovations that
immediately would have been on the heels
of all the tragedies that
started to happen um you know 100 years
of hindsight make seat belts seem
completely obvious um and also seemed
sensible that
that we would implement safety measures
but that's not
really what happened right so what
happened
is that there was this long-winded
almost hundred year or over 100 year
process
where we had to go from um the first
gasoline-powered car
the one that she was in was just
steam-powered right the first
gasoline-powered car in 1875 and there's
this sort of range of
of innovation around safety features so
they invented
crumple zones and softer interiors this
whole set of features that they did all
the way up into the anthropomorphic test
devices that we use now and even past
even more recently they've started to be
more inclusive about anthropomorphic
test devices
which were generally just like six foot
um
uh six foot tall bodies with flat chests
and broad shoulders
right and so now we've got ones for dogs
and they want guns for babies and all
this so
this is this constant process of
innovation so if you look at the
timeline of
of when these things were actually
invented and
then you start to bring in some other
aspects of when they actually
were standardized and became mandatory
and if you look at a lot of other
technological
paths telecommunications whatever that
make the case may be in innovation
there's this path somebody invents
something
crazy train bad stuff happens because
that's what happens when you innovate
you don't really know what's going to
happen
people start inventing safety things
around it and then
industry says we can't do that because
you're going to stifle innovation or we
can't do that because it's too expensive
customers say i don't want to use that
that's too controlling people i saw
an email i own a volvo it wasn't and by
accident today
i got an email from volvo because there
was some recall that's the other thing
recalls safety recalls
that said did you know that when we
invented i thought it was like
serendipitous because i was giving this
talk and mentioning this guy
when we invented the three-point you
know seat belt
people thought that it was like a
violation of their personal rights
to be restrained in that way right and
so stuff that we really take for gana
and just sort of slide on
it really takes a while to ingest that
and what always gets it done
and i know it's unfortunate is just
legislation and regulation
right so you can see that line when the
the the un says this in 1958 and the u.s
and being very u.s centered in this talk
um in 1966
then people are like okay if you're
going to make us do it we're going to do
it these things are going to be
mandatory
so that's kind of the path of how things
happened so the history of automotive
product technology
you know it just took this sort of
meandering path um and it took this
hundred years of doing it so safety is a
process
right and safety is never a destination
it will never
be all right but we have to start
somewhere right and so if you think hard
about these early innovation cycles
um as well you can't
govern and control something that
doesn't exist
so early on when you're creating new
technologies or conceiving
of new ideas there's really nothing to
write safety standards for
you have to get to this point of this is
a thing and then you put it out there
and of course people who make things
think they know how the thing make
works because they made it but the
reality is technologies always surprise
us they always do things that we had
never had any idea that they could do
and i think we're seeing that a lot
online right now
so that's one story so let's go to
another story this picture might be more
familiar to people although some of you
might have been mary ward
fans she was actually a kind of hoppin
lady
um she was really into microscopes and
i'm wondering
she's riding around in this prototype
skiing powered thing in 1869 that's kind
of badass
but anyhow um may 7th 2016
jason joshua brown excuse me joshua
brown entrepreneur he's riding around
his
tesla model s right he's got the
autopilot functionality engaged
and that functionality didn't recognize
a tractor trailer that pulled into his
path
i think many of us who follow has
followed this know this story
car goes under the tractor trailer goes
through a fence hits a power pole and he
dies
instantly at the scene so this is the
first fatality that has to do with
an automobile with autopilot engaged and
immediate again
people were horrified i'm horrified i
feel
emotional now even talking about this
you know
this was a human being with a family and
loved ones and he looks super modern and
you know he's standing by his car and
he's super happy it's a really sad thing
but again there was no general public
concern saying tesla stop
until this is absolutely safe right
we're willing to take a certain amount
of risk when it comes to
innovation and so innovation not just
sound heartless
does involve a certain level of risk but
so you know
why am i talking about this if i'm just
saying it's all going to be you know
risky
i think that at this at a certain point
um
when you have a product or service
that's in place and and you're getting
ready to scale it you really
can stop and consider and take a safety
assessment
and at least understand the risks
involved in the risk that are inherent
in the work that you're doing
and i think if there's a criticism of
digital it's that we don't do that
we don't do that enough in this space
and i think there's a lot of reasons for
that and i'll
talk about that a lot as we move on so
um digital safety is just really
interesting topic to me i used to talk a
lot about digital governance
um and i still talk a lot about digital
governance but people don't like that
word as much
so i'm going to give you a little bit of
a history of me not because i'm ego
centered but because the path that i
took to get to this point of
talking about safety is
not interesting as an interesting i'm an
interesting person it's just i think
it's relevant how about that it's
relevant
so i was an undergrad philosophy major
and i um
was not the philosophy major that got to
wear the beret and smoke the cigarettes
and think about my feelings and all my
feels
i thought that's what i was going to get
but i ended up at the university of
north carolina in greensboro not chapel
hill
it's a very small department and they're
professors who were super into symbolic
logic
so you're talking to a woman who had
hated math i know i'm not with my people
right here but i really hated math i was
not bad at it but i really didn't like
it
i ended up in this department where i
just had to take like a whole bunch of
symbolic logic
and so that was great it made me not not
hate math and i ended up writing my
senior thesis with a professor who was
really into artificial intelligence on
keith gunderson's
mentality of machines and so that was
all accidental i was not
really into it i started out a music
major but i ended up
in this kind of weird thing so as a
result of those skills i actually can
code
the only thing that i can code is
prologue right so
that's it because it's it's relationship
to symbolic logic
that was a natural fit for me so that's
not maybe not the most practical thing
but that's me just trying to spread out
some of my geek credentials
so i thought i wanted to be a philosophy
professor i went to columbia
university as a philosophy fellow for a
year i knew almost instantly it was a
mistake
um so i spent a lot of time at the
metropolitan opera listening to opera
and i also spent a lot of time emailing
my beau who is a computer science
master's degree candidate someplace else
and that was my first exposure to the
internet using pine
to send email to my boyfriend so i wish
i had a better story
a more exciting story about a technology
adoption in lisa
but this is really a stumbling path um
so i left grad school i had a mac that i
had bought for grad school and i started
playing around with hyper card
right so this was my first experience
with anything hyper
text-y in in the language um what i also
ended up doing was because i had these
computer skills
and i was in new york city and i could
write really well and i was reasonably
smart
i started temping and at that time
temping
from an admin capacity meant uh
you know word processing so word star
where you have to actually tag
words and so i would get these really
super high level temp
jobs at these global multinational
corporations where they put me in when
you know
the ceo's secretary went on a holiday or
a maternity leave they'd slap me in
so why am i telling you this um one
because
i got this tremendous exposure to
executives
right i started to see how people very
senior and very large organizations
act what they know what they don't know
how they're catered to and how they're
not catered to
where their strengths and weaknesses are
also in that
whole time i also got exposed to early
collaboration software
like lotus notes and so i did early
lotus notes development
so um
ended up uh
getting married i got pregnant
and was home on maternity leave and i
was bored and
a friend of mine who lived in silicon
valley this is 1995
bought me a 96 600 baud modem and an
html book as a maternity gift because i
was bored so i taught myself hypertext
markup language
packed my bags moved to silicon valley
and ended up um
after coding pages for netscape which
was kind of fun
ended up at cisco systems now this job
was the absolute gift and the direct
connection to what i do now
so much as when i had been in new york
and i'd seen large corporations and how
they function and what happens at the
executive level
i also was inside cisco systems right
when the commercial web was hitting
they had a huge website they were doing
multi-channel delivery they were doing
usability studies sophisticated
things with multi with a metadata
management
a lot of things that some companies
really have difficulty doing right now
but it also showed me something else
about people and if you haven't noticed
a theme
about this is i love technology but i
love more the people who make technology
i'm very very interested in what people
do with the technology and how they make
it as a part of the team
and so what i noticed that even though
cisco systems understood the internet
and the web
because they would given what they do
they had a
horrible time managing their online
properties
right they did they just they thought
about them they couldn't get any
consistency so that
made me understand that just because you
can build something
or make something or understand it does
not mean
that you know how to manage it well
right and so i think
that which seems like a very very
simplistic thing is something that's
really obvious that's happening
um right now in our digital spaces just
because you can make something
doesn't necessarily mean that you can
manage it well or that you can manage
the outcome of it consistently
so i quit cisco in 1999 i've been
consulting and the culmination of that
has been that um i'm working to put
words around digital governance which is
really about establishing
a vocabulary and framework for putting
into place
good decision-making mechanisms around
rules so
an easy thing would be you know a
taxonomy
that's a set of rules you know visual
device design components are rules there
are deeper deeper things
in the technology stack usually when
there are governance problems that
manifest as a
a discordant online presence or an
unsafe online presence there's usually
not a consistent set of rules
that are happening and being
consistently applied and used inside the
organization
and so i go in and help them do that i
help them organize that and it really is
more psychology than it is anything else
it's about control and power um and who
inside the organization
thinks that they ought to be able to
make those rules there's two different
types of organizations that i tend to
work with
in this capacity and they're very
different and i think might be resonant
for some of you all who are working on
new technologies one are
companies that existed prior to the
advent of the commercial web
and then which i call transforming and
then companies that existed
um after so native digitally native
companies
they have different types of problems
transforming companies have a difficulty
ingesting digital and because it
displaces certain activities internally
and their power structures that it
messes with but they oftentimes accept
the concept of governance and know that
there need to be rules
and know that they need to manage things
effectively so their challenge is
getting away from the way things used to
be and ingesting the new technologies
and understanding how to capitalize on
them and use them for digitally native
companies it's the other side
they know how to use these technologies
they're all about net technologies but
they don't know how to run a company
right and not knowing how to run a
company in a large digital environment
means that
you really don't know what's going on
and you don't have checks and balances
in place to ensure that what you're
building is being built with intent
it's just basically like growth gone
wild right and so they're
immature as a business so there are two
different types of um
of challenges and so i've been doing
digital governance for a while
and after a while people are kind of
like she's the party pooper
um uh people who work in an agile
environment are like you just want us to
stop and
make a bunch of rules and do stuff and i
was like no i don't
i want you to have a framework through
which you make things
and you can do that fast or slow that's
entirely up to you
um but i was also realizing that there
were some people that i'm
working with that did have rules they
did have a governing framework put in
place
but what they were making was still not
great
like they're on the list of bad digital
people
right and so it's like okay so they are
governing but the substance of what
they're doing isn't great and that's
when i really started to think there's
this other component
that marries with governance which is
around ethics the morality of you
what you make the culture of the
business that you're working in
and the context of the society in which
the products and services that you
create
are deployed and so that's when i
thought it's safety
people really want to feel safe online
right so i think that you know no matter
what kind of good or bad experience that
that you have
online or what your opinion is about
what's online
there's you know there are pornographic
sites online and there are sites for
children
both of those extreme cases of things
have safety measures in place you know
for the user so
people want to interact in their
experience in online
by their choice and wherever they want
are they want to feel safe
they don't want to be traumatized they
want to feel like they're in control and
i think
not feeling that is a lot of what's
going on right now so i've teamed with
andy vitale who's a user experience
expert and designer because that's not
my competency
to try and talk about designing for
safety right and
what would it look like to take safety
into consideration as you're designing
and building
so that's what i'm going to talk about
for the rest of this time of just kind
of like
talking about how products become safe
talking defining digital safety and
giving you some tips on how to improve
safety as things move
move forward so um i'm a
kind of a basics person right and i
you know um christina mentioned like i'm
always noticing
you know things that people aren't
noticing it's not that i'm particularly
bright
it's that i think i'm smart enough but
so i'm not just not dismissing myself
it's just that i
often go back to the fundamentals i
think the fundamentals are really
important and often times when there's
an
error the error is in the fundamental
it's not in some complicated thing
so let's talk about these two terms
digital and safety
and so digital is really interesting
when i work with folks
one of the um first things i say to them
so it's digital governance that i'm
usually working with them on
or now talking about safe digital safety
for them it's like you know what what do
you mean when you say digital
and they're like well it really depends
right so if i'm working with an
automobile manufacturer it's anything
from their
um their marketing website that talks
about their business and has their press
releases
all the way through their marketing
collateral materials all the way through
the car configurator
and all of the data and information that
goes into that and
then that tucks into some supply chain
related things
in the back end all the way to you know
okay
autonomous driving so they have a very
broad arcing
thing that's all about digital for them
but i'm talking to my local restaurant
you know
last night i went and got indian food
she's complaining because the prices
aren't right
on the on the menu you know on the
online menu so it can be very small
case or or not but then there are these
other two things that are
obviously related to digital spaces
which are the web and the internet
right so they're all interrelated but i
think it's just really important to get
that the web is a container
that holds all the stuff we build and
put online
so if the web isn't safe it's not safe
because what we're building and putting
online isn't safe which means maybe
if what we build and put online is safer
and better
that quality will go up so there's also
um
internet governance and safety related
issues that are about feeds and speeds
net neutrality there's
all these sets of things that are
interrelated to one another
and i see them and i honor them and i
hear them ww
is all about standards um i'll talk
about that a little bit later on
of just sort of like a lot of what's
really helpful
um about the web early on was that we
had the w3c and this
set of standards that's just sort of
sitting right there so there's a there
are rules there are rules around these
technologies
so just for the purposes of this talk
i'm not talking about
the w3c and the governance of the world
wide web and i'm not talking about iso
governance of the internet i'm not
talking about the fact that the un
says that access to the internet is a
human right i'm not saying they're not
important i'm saying
at this moment i'm not talking about
that what i'm talking about
is what businesses and people build and
put online
right so when i say digital that is what
i am
talking about um without a doubt so
that's my thing for
digital now safety is is more
interesting um
when i originally was thinking about
this idea um and started talking about
it with andy the first thing that i went
into
into my mind was consumer products
let's just cheat safety like a like a
let's just cheat the web like a consumer
product
right we have all these safety standards
and you know i got a recall for my volvo
when bad things happen there are
mechanisms we know how to keep things
safe
and you know the web's interesting
because it is this combination
of like stuff and acts transactions and
activities that happen online
um as well as stuff that's fcc related
right so there really are no controls in
the consumer product area governmentally
for controlling what happens online
it all happens on the fcc so i think you
know an area of research for me over the
next year will be
to try and tease that part and to
understand what is the very nature
of a digital product and services and is
the digital functionality that
is for instance i i don't i'm not
diabetic but i have
food sensitivities and so i have a
continuous uh glucose
blood monitor in my arm right so i could
pick my phone up if it were here
and tap my arm and find out what my
blood sugar is so and then that
information
goes online so what's that right is that
a consumer product or is that digital or
whatever so these kind of
creepy weird in between spaces are
things that are worth talking about
but for the sake of having a definition
and for having a high level one this is
the one that we came up with which is
this idea of minimizing
emotional economic physical and
psychological harm to
any human being and to society
right and so it's it's it's
intentionally vague
probably any type of harm that you can
think about
should fit underneath there i'm curious
if you can think of things that don't
fit underneath there
to me inclusion points to any human
being um
there are you know online suicides that
are happening
there's all kinds of crazy stuff that's
happening online i think there's two
sets of responsibilities
that are neglected in the digital space
one is that product owners need to
actually
understand the level of safety of the
products and services they create and
put online
right and i don't believe that that's
happening in a good way
um i think people make things and they
put them on the line online and they
wait for them to break
and then you know the collateral damage
is on the general public and on users
and i will say that in innovation and
technology that happens
right but we're at a point now where we
know enough where we can actually start
mitigating that
the second half of it is i think that
consumers people who use the product and
services
have a responsibility the equivalent of
fastening your seat belt
you can put a three-point seat belt in
my car but i have to fasten it
right so it's a partnership that society
has around doing these things
i think there are so that's my
definition of safety
i think that there are safety people
have agency there's different types of
folks with agency in this system
it's a broad broad group innovators so
these are people who are the institutors
and advocates of new ideas
probably many of you right um it could
be a person with a smart algorithm
it could be a person with a title like
founder ceo
product owner product manager angel
investor venture capitalist these are
people
feeding that that pipeline of innovation
that keeps things
moving along so well the next ones are
makers we always focus on them they
could be architects engineers front end
back-end data architects
you know quantum computing people i mean
it's just a broad
sense of people who are actually making
and building the things that we put
online this skill set is super rich
and we tend to be focused on them and
there's a lot of makers who end up being
innovators they're innovative maker
founders and that's a challenge
um the next set of folks that i like to
talk about are rule makers
um true and due to my heart rule makers
governance policies and standards
bearers
it's broad right so it's not just
policies and standards bearers for a
particular product
in a particular business it's also the
government
right um industry-wide standards
um things that pull um pull globally w3c
isoc right that i mentioned the thing
about the un access to the internet so
there's all kinds of rulemakers
that are also in this system and they
have a role to play and so
there are facilitators and bridges these
are in some ways my favorites because
they're kind of elusive
they're about delivery and
accountability so in the context of
building a product or service
that might be a scrum master or a
project manager an analyst
who's actually feeding that mechanism
but outside of that it's industry
experts
and watch dogs it could be marketers
pumping up
and facilitating the use of technologies
inside of that
and so these are people who are are you
know somebody says
here's a spec for rss but how does it
get spread out and used across the board
so that we actually can
normalize certain behaviors so it's a
super super important role and i don't
think identified
um closely enough all the time and then
last but not least there's the rest of
us
the people who use these online products
and services so every one of these
groups of people have a role to play in
safety i think it's important to call
out these people individually or these
groups of people individually because
a lot of times you know the arguments
that make me so frustrated online now is
you know
something crazy happens online pick a
day any day
something crazy is going to happen
online and somebody points a finger and
says
you you can fix it and it's like these
are systemic
problems that's why i said at the top of
it yes there are people who
hold a tremendous amount of control over
things that happen online i am not
letting those people off the hook
but there's a whole set of people who
actually
feed and support that mechanism and so
i'm not giving up i anyone where they
are can do
something um even if it's just a
consumer deciding to actually
read the freaking privacy policy or
reconfigure
you know the permissions on some of
their social media accounts instead of
just letting them be whatever the
defaults are
so now we're going to talk about um
how safety issues arise and so this is i
alluded to this a little bit when we
were talking about mary ward and
and um and uh joshua
earlier and their tragic accidents um
but
i think you know i watched a couple of
the talks um
just getting ready for this just to kind
of warm myself up and there's the
interesting one about sisyphus i was
like oh
i think they're gonna actually say the
same thing i said sort of and it sort of
was
but it's there's this path that happens
um
all the time over and over again when
when you have a new technology it's a
very simple path
so the first thing you have is this
innovation so this is this eureka
experience of an idea of something that
we can do something that we can build
something that we can have
while that's happening there's this
organic growth i mean it happened with
the telephone during the organic growth
people tried different ways to do
different
to do it so steam powered electric you
know
gas powered engines for for automobiles
same thing with the telephone there were
a million different telephones before
they finally got to something where
they're like
this thing works so i want to point out
that while you're arcing up to figuring
out stuff
that's where you get those you know
crazy pictures of the wright brothers
crashing airplanes into barns
right it's dangerous it is dangerous
sticky work which is why not everyone's
a bleeding edge adopter
right i like to fly but i wouldn't have
gotten on an early airplane
i know i wouldn't have done that right
so but there comes this point where
you've actually got something viable
repeatable
that you think you can scale into an
actual product and at that point
you need to start thinking about making
it
safe right you need to start thinking
about making rules for it
now here's the thing you may be and i'll
get killed for this
by someone but you maybe don't need to
make it safe
but you at least need to assess the
safety of it
right you need to understand what it can
and cannot do i think there are
definitely some bottom line
must-haves when it comes to keeping
things safe
but i think making something
absolutely safe oftentimes stifles it
i'm not talking about inclusion which i
think is a basic i'm not talking about a
lot of basic
human things that haven't happened in
digital spaces but i'm just saying
there's
probably going to be some room in there
for for there to be some safety issues
that are known that don't get
mitigated early and they'll work out
over time
now what happens if you don't do that is
you fall into this sort of chaotic pit
of nonsense
and that's a large opportunity for harm
and risk
right so you've got a product you've
decided that it works you're
to scale it you're going to bring it to
a large group of people you offer it out
you haven't checked whether or not it's
safe
people get on it and you're basically
like alpha testing on them
right and i know other people have said
that as well but that's a huge amount
that's a huge safety risk for people
so people go crazy i think that's where
we are now oh my god it's completely
unsafe
this is crazy it's your fault it's your
fault it's your fault there's many
debates and arguments
over time and then we climb through this
process
right people go we ought to have some
rules it's like okay we ought to have
some rules and what should the rules be
we argue about that for a while we drive
to rules eventually we get to a basic
set of rules or standards
about what you shouldn't do around the
safety of the product and service
and then it continues then you have this
glorious spot where the thing's
safe and profitable everybody can fly on
an airplane
or cars you know like like just safety
is an issue with cars
but most of them are pretty safe right
there's variability there's just people
just aren't even thinking about it
now the challenge with that is that
it things get commoditized and they
start to level out and then it's like
price like what's the cheapest version
they're kind of all the same it's like
the way clone systems were
before we started doing voiceover ip you
know you order a phone system for your
office and it was like
color how many lines do you want and
price
they all basically did the same thing
right and so they're what those things
weren't differentiators so when you get
to that point
that's an opportunity for something to
swoop in and completely disrupt that
business model which is why
businesses that can cycle through that
safe and profitable thing and
ride over an innovation into a new wave
are very rare
right it's very rare for businesses to
do that they either reinvent themselves
go out of business or require to sustain
that level
so um growth i thought i took this
actual slide out but anyhow
this is my favorite dna slide because
when i timed it i didn't have time
but this is my favorite dna slide where
i like to talk about growth
and a blueprint for a set of rules and
i'm making a very simple point here
which is that things do not scale with
integrity
without a blueprint right that's just it
just doesn't work
and i'm sure somebody you guys are super
smart are going to come up as an example
that works i'm not saying that can't
scale but with integrity
so you know for people it's dna if you
look through nature you'll find all
kinds of things
for industry it's um robotics and
replication and
assembly lines so there's just a
systematized pattern where things happen
and the reason why i brought this up in
the first place is
i often don't think there's anything new
under the sun
right because everyone always likes to
say digital it's completely new and it's
like no it's not
you know we had document management
before we had data flow before
we had all these other things before and
so i'm definitely a mismatcher from in
nlp language if somebody says something
something
i'm going to say no but in this case i
was actually searching for what is the
kind of
interesting unique thing about digital
and this growth
and i think one of the unique things
about it is that
usually on this end there's a few people
using the product
and then when you get to some fairly
decent governance and some fairly decent
rules and some fairly decent set that's
when you get into this
commoditized everything doesn't wait
till the very end but there's just this
surge that happens but because
if you remember the slide when i was
talking about the internet and the world
wide web those are two
super standardized technologies like
under the water
iceberg technologies that support
digital spaces
so you've got the internet starting what
in the 1950s or something like that
and tim berners-lee paper on the world
wide web
was in the late 80s she wrote that paper
at cern
i should probably know that or write it
in my notes but in any case they were
there and the w3c
was in place with web standards so what
happened
was that so we had this switch where the
commercial web turned on
like in the early mid 90s and people
jumped on it and it ramped really hard
because it was already standardized
that's unusually
that's unusual in a technology
innovation environment from just the
sort of things that i've been reading
and so that's a unique thing about
digital and i think it validates
everyone's intuition
which was there is incredible amount of
fast growth but that fast growth doesn't
mean maturity
but i think we kind of duped ourselves
into thinking maybe that
fast growth that we were in a more
mature place than we actually
actually are and i think we're finding
out that we're not
so um last thing to finish up really in
just exploring this idea
is what can we do now
and i'm these are sort of gentle things
that we are that really focus on
depending on who you are in that
community of agents that i mentioned
earlier um
i think that there's the first thing to
do
is really understand where we are in the
context of this and i'm going to make
a couple of statements in a couple of
predictions one of them is it's still
early
and it's hard sometimes for human beings
to understand that the path of
innovation and growth
spans over the in a in a span that's
greater than their lifetime
so i hear people saying i've had the web
my whole life or
for me i've been doing this for 25 30
years it doesn't matter
right innovation curves don't happen
don't care
how long the life this you know span of
a human life is
has nothing to do with you or i being
able to see the end of the story
for this so um the other thing is that
digital's foundation tech foundational
technologies the internet and the web
are still poorly and inconsistently
governed
right so the worldwide and world wide
web is significant
i mean tim berners-lee is kicking as
hard as he can in the pool with the
world wide web foundation
to try and pull pull this thing together
you know he sort of unleashed this beast
onto the world and it's just gone crazy
and so um that's as it should be in in
some ways um just the craziness of it
and him trying to leash it back in
but you know there are parts of the
world where access the internet is
variable there's parts of the world
where full access
to the web is web is variable we haven't
come to an agreement
even in an individual country about how
things ought to operate
when it comes to data privacy and
security there's gdpr
and then there's the way that we're
doing it here in the us and then there's
the way you're doing it in california
which is hard to enforce by the way um
in terms of you know just how these data
protection privacies work so we don't
have an idea of
how the rules should be so we're working
in an immature environment
so these are the two predictions that i
have around here which is
that dot that said governance we're
probably still
25 to 30 years away from it 25 to 30
years away from saying
here's a good set of rules about how we
should operate online
both nationally and globally right or
maybe
you know interstellarly who knows the
martians might come while we're
while we're working out and solve solve
the problem for us that would
give us something else to pay attention
to um so
those types of governance and rules and
safety rules that come into place
will really happen incrementally and by
intentional design and there will be
additional tragedy
right that that is i can't think of a
technology where that hasn't happened
and i'm not wishing it through but i
think it's good to go in wide-eyed
about how these things happen and what
can happen in this type of environment
and then i think it's going to be at
least 50 years until we get to the point
of car-like safety
i don't think not a lot of people
although you know it was interesting i
was in senegal
a couple years ago just on a holiday and
you know the cars got no windows
the gear shift barely works and this one
taxi cab that i was in the guy literally
got in what do you call the thing that
you tighten the lug nuts with
um in the car whatever that thing is he
would get out every couple kilometers
and tighten
the wheel right so so it was just
you know those things are all relative
you know safety is relative so it's
never going to be like
just this span out thing i bet that car
was safe once but it wasn't safe
anymore so those things are really
contextual but i think we're really far
out
so what that means is you know we don't
have to wait
for that i think we're all part of that
process
and all of those safety agents have a
role to play and so i really just in the
last
few minutes like to talk about what role
each of those groups of people
that i mentioned earlier can play right
now
to raise their level of awareness around
safety and so for
technology innovators they have to take
ownership for the safety of the products
and services that they fund build and
release right you can't
punt that stuff out into the field and
expect somebody else to deal with it
you need to be responsible for it so
leadering is more than just thinking of
new ways to exploit technology
it's about creating a safe environment
for the employees that work
allowing them to talk about safety
and and to bring those things up and
promoting a culture
of safety establishing guiding
principles
that reflect the ethical framework of
your company
now i might not choose as a consumer to
use your product because i don't like
your ethical framework but you should at
least
have one right and that is the
responsibility of innovators and i think
for the most part they tend to fail in
this space they're still acting like it
was 20 years ago
and that you can sort of fly by your
seat of your pants and not be
responsible
i think it's starting to shift but i
don't think it's shifting hard enough
i think for people who actually build
and make products
they need to realize and honor the truth
that upstream safety is
better than downstream anything upstream
is better than downstream
engineering safety into a product is
easier than
fixing a product that's broken and
causing strategy
tragedy i think we're seeing a lot of
that right now with a lot of the big
social software companies just having to
fix stuff their whole business model is
floating on top of
this thing that doesn't really work but
they can't and won't unplug it because
they're going to unplug the company
so engineering safety in from the top
safety assessment should be part of the
conception
prototyping and build process should
constantly be checking for safety
constantly understanding what could
potentially go wrong
and you should not bring things to scale
that you don't know are not safe
or that you don't understand the safety
of
or that you understand the safety of and
you haven't communicated that safety
to the consumer one of the interesting
exceptions to the consumer protection
safety act
was firearms and i was like yeah well of
course we know that those
aren't safe right and so but people
choose to use them anyway
i think what's going on in digital
spaces is that makers aren't really
thinking about that
and so they're not giving consumers the
opportunity to understand whether or not
something's safe or not safe
because they're not articulating it um i
think
rulemakers need to really broaden their
perspective perspective
beyond sort of the functional product
integrity and profit
and regulation right so i wrote a piece
a few years
back called does it delight does it
parse does it pay
right and so basically if consumers love
it
and they're buying it and the code works
then we're cool so i think rulemakers
need to
broaden that and start to bring in some
of the ethical emotional and social
considerations
and impact of the software when they're
actually building rules around that
and those rules need that needs to
happen at the product level and it needs
to happen at the national level and it
needs to happen
at the international level um what do
what rules do we need to put in place in
order for
things to be safe um i think for
facilitators and bridges they
have to actively promote and maintain a
culture of safety
i think this is the richest place right
now there are a lot of facilitators
and bridges in organizations like isoc
the w3c
the webb foundation and just a long list
in academia
we're actually starting to have these
conversations about safety
and whether or not things how things
could be safe in a digital space and why
they should be
safe in a digital space so i think just
considering
that and talking more about safety as a
concept
across vertical market spaces and across
geographies is going to be super
important and that work can be doing is
being done right now
can continue to be done and i think for
the last piece for consumers
is you know they and we just have a
responsibility to investigate
the safety of of the digital products
that we use and we're gonna have to
fasten our our digital seat belts
because it's gonna be a bumpy ride i
think that maturity curve that i showed
you is an inevitable
thing i think awareness of the maturity
curve and
awareness of how we move through these
phases of safety
and governance moving from innovation to
commodity
understanding how that works is really
important will maybe help us move a
little bit faster
but you know it's there's a lot of
people on the planet that's a lot of
organizing
i mean for those of you who work in
inside large
organizations or even in a in an
academic environment it's hard
to organize people and get them to do
the same thing so
um it's just going to take while for
that to happen even with the best of
intentions
so i hope that that was kind of like
a good sort of exploration i'm curious
about ideas that you might have
it's sort of a just a framework to think
about and hopefully can inform
you in the work that you're doing and
will
make you a little bit more thoughtful
about how you can maybe integrate safety
in some of the work that you're doing or
at least in the thought or in the
community of people
that you work with a couple last points
safety must be fought for with intent
i'm a big
proponent of intentionality you have to
mean it you have to want it
work where you are you don't have to go
out and have a protest sound you don't
have to tweet to everybody but that
thing that you're working on
right now that idea that you're building
right now think about
safety in that context and be brave i
think there are a lot of people
um in the digital space who lack
managerial courage
they won't make the hard decisions and
they don't want to stick out as
being the one who's kind of rocking the
boat and i think that can oftentimes be
very very challenging
so i think being brave is uh is super
important
and i'll support you if you need
somebody
in your corner not that that's much of
anything but i think there's a lot of
knees out in the world and
a lot of times all we need is one person
to sort of step out and make a statement
and other people will follow so please
be brave at all possible
and bring it on always bring your big
self and your best
self and uh i hope that was really a
helpful conversation
thank you very much we
are um so the the inaudible collapse are
happening
uh and we are
uh transitioning to conversation q a um
if you're willing to stop sharing your
screen so everyone can see you uh
full screen that would be amazing thank
you
um so panelists feel free to unmute
yourselves and ask questions or
to simply um uh just raise your hand in
the interface
students i linked uh to hci.st
qa if you'd like to submit something
it's just behind a stanford login wall
to deal with zoom bombing
um i'll kick it off with one question
well uh while folks are getting ready
so i
i i think that this question of how we
govern ourselves i agree there's there's
been a lot and i've
myself made errors in like waiting too
long to figure some of this stuff out
and it's come back to
really uh haunt the effort and i guess
what i
i have a really pragmatic question which
is that
when is too early and when is too late
so like clearly
if um i guess what i'm there are some
cases where
you're trying to imagine harms and you
want to do that say up very much up
front
but if we're thinking specifically about
governance
there are points at which we don't know
what we're doing yet and then there are
points where it's too late
because we should have figured it out
earlier
so are there do you have any rules of
thumb you give about when
sort of the goldilocks well i think
there's i think the way that you're
talking about the problem
is not the way that i would think about
the problem which is that
what you're saying sounds like if you
know that
there's a problem you should fix it
right
and that's not what i'm saying i'm
saying that you should know that there's
a problem
and understand the risk involved in
proceeding
with that in place tesla is a really
great example there's this big
announcement today they're putting all
this autopilot software
into their cars and rolling it out or
whatever and i know it's been three four
years
since the accident that i mentioned but
we know that something
not good is not going to happen right at
some point with that
because it's a new technology and i'm
not saying that i'm not bashing
i'm not it's just inevitable so i think
just being clear-eyed about that
doesn't mean you don't proceed but i bet
you they know where the vulnerabilities
are and i
that's my criticism is that people
proceed without evaluating their
vulnerabilities
right so i think you know particularly
with some of the in
the dot com spaces you know the the wide
access that allowed all this spoofing
and bots or whatever it just didn't have
to happen that way
right there that wasn't complicated
right you could have thought of a use
case of abuse
very early on and at least known it
known it
been looking for it and then when it
started to ramp up
mitigate it immediately so you could
have a safety plan
in your back pocket and go okay we're
going to implement and see what happens
we know this bad thing can happen
and we're ready for it right and so i
think that's what's not
happening that component and i honestly
think it's because you have people in
there who are
passionate about the technology right
and
good-hearted or that's on the good side
good-hearted on the good side or just
lack awareness like they're
sociologically
um narrow like you know algorithm bias
i can't freaking get through an airport
on that face
recognition did i mean i travel the
world and i it's difficult for me to get
through
somebody just wasn't thinking do i
aggressively think they were trying to
attack people of color
by doing that no but what a narrow
existence that that wasn't even a
consideration
so i think having that inclusion and
thinking about those things early
will keep bad stuff from being
engineered in and it's so
am i answering your question like i
don't think there's a goldilocks moment
i think it's part of the system and it's
a part of checks and balances you do the
same thing with the technology
this works good enough right it doesn't
work exactly every how we want it but it
works good enough that we can try it out
right i think what i'm in some sense
trying to drive that is that there are
definitely some
there's there's a totally reasonable
position that says
safety first before you make any
decisions about anything you should have
a safety audit about the ideas that
you're pursuing
who it's going to harm and how like
before you even decide
to go to go for it and then there's some
people are gonna say
well you should wait a little bit until
you've like decided that
this is a direction you want to go to
which the response is well at that point
you've made the decision
and you're you've made the decision to
harm people so i guess what i'm trying
to get a sense of it
are you gonna sort of fall on the side
of people who say
no like you you need a sort of you need
to put safety into you
you know when we teach design right is
do we do need finding and is safety part
of the need finding
process is it part of the ideation
process does it come after ideation but
before prototyping like
how how should we concretely weave this
in i think i think you're right that i'm
going to fall on the
what you're presenting as the more
conservative side or the safer side
but not for everything right so i mean
all things aren't equal
like there's no reason for um you know
facial recognition
technology not to be inclusive out of
the gate
right but there's some other stuff that
maybe could drive a little crazy for a
while
right because it's not as systemically
damaging so i think there's subtlety to
it
it's not like you know check this box i
mean that's what i think makes it so
difficult
the breadth of what is happening online
is so staggering i mean there's stuff in
there's nanotechnologies and people's
body that
are connected i mean it's just it's
completely insane so
the level of safety and care for the
thing stuck in my arm
really better be higher than you know
for some other things that are happening
in the digital space and i think what's
happening
is innovators and early founders and
makers
don't have that holistic sense of
looking at stuff
it's like this sort of hyper focus which
is required to get it done which is why
that community of people of founding and
creating and conceiving of things
probably needs to be more inclusive
right not to stop it but just to
to broaden the perspective yeah as my
own
closing comment here and then we'll open
it um to anyone else who has comments
um um i was on a panel a couple days ago
where
a comment i was made that i thought was
really incisive which was
that if you want to look to the sort of
future harms that are going to happen
through a system
all you really need to do is go look at
the harms that are currently
affecting marginalized groups and
you you're there i mean people ask me
all the time like you know
they call me governance girl for like
the last 20 years it's supposed to be i
almost got a cape
you know and a whip but it was just you
know it was it was ridiculous people
would make fun of me
you know at these events and they're
like oh you're always looking into the
wrong side of thing and it's like you
know i grew up
upper middle class i'm fine financially
i'm not a
you know you're you're you know black
america that can grow up in financially
disadvantaged circumstances but i am
underneath this brown skin and i've
operated in it
as well from a social perspective stuff
can go wrong and bad things can go
and can can happen and i know that and
the fact that i know that means that i'm
a little bit more tuned into risk
like the world is not a magic carpet
ride for me i know things can so
go bad so i'm more inclined to go okay
what could potentially go bad then maybe
somebody who grew up in an environment
or lives in a world that sort of wraps
them up a little bit more safely
and carries them through things and so
that's you know maybe a little bit of a
political thing to say but i think it's
important
and so um that's why inclusion is
important in these environments
hi uh thank you um very much for laying
out the framework and
what all needs to be done and all the
different people that need to do it
i wonder if you could tell a story about
um
sometime when you helped a company or a
piece of technology
or whatever uh work their way towards
finding their three-point seat belt
wow so i don't i don't do safety for a
living i do governance for a living
but i can say that um
and the majority of my work has been
helping large global multinational
corporations or
people in like the ngo community like
the un
govern digital so write rules for
digital and so to a certain extent some
of those rules are about
you know keeping things safe so that's
just my my full disclosure but i think
probably one of my most interesting
stories in this space has to do with one
of your neighbors down there
which is intel right so i worked i
worked with intel and it was great
because they called me and they already
had a digital governance
you know fairly senior person working in
that in that space
and we were actually effectively able to
get people globally and
locally aligned around following a same
set of rules
now in their case it was not about
safety i'll be completely honest
it was really about saving money in
their marketing spaces
being more impactful from a sales
environment um
but they were very very effective in it
they were data driven
um what i learned in that project
honestly
was how much the culture of the
organization and the people involved
impacted their ability to actually
create a
create a rule set so we're inside an
organization that makes a zero defect
product
that was it was the project was half
done right already so it was just like
you say there are rules and you must
follow them i got to talk to the
the person who was in charge of supply
chain management
and talk about how they got diverse
constituents to align around a set of
rules
right so i'm not directly answering your
question because to be honest with you i
don't
i'm still exploring the ideas of safety
and trying to define the ideas
of safety around this and my hope is
that um
got my plan with a couple of different
places to actually be sitting and doing
some research around this and to do some
test cases and use cases
right around um with some large
organizations i've consulted for a long
time so i have a lot of relationships
and that's good
because i really want to prove the point
i want to learn more about
risk and mitigation and safety plans in
manufacturing
right so there's all these sorts of
things there's people already know how
to be safe
right there's already processes for
being safe and plans for being safe so i
want to learn
how to take those plans and apply those
rules in the business context
which is why i'm working on the book so
you're asking me a question asked me in
like three years
so thanks very stimulating talk
hello lisa i so my question was
stems from thinking that the legal
system
yes and potential lawsuits wow
disincentives for finding
risks and dangers in the technology that
you're creating because
if in discovery it's found out that you
knew about
a potential problem right then your
liability has actually increased so it's
is the argument that it's better to just
kind of
put your head in the sand um
what do you think so yes
and i i would argue yes
i spent a lot of time i spent a lot of
time
talking with attorneys as you could well
imagine and i'll the the biggest
weakness in
in them honestly is i don't think
depending on where you are
if you're inside of a transforming
company that's not particularly
digitally centered or that has a
business model that hasn't been but
they're moving into it like pharma
as an example or different aspects of
healthcare they're starting to create
these wearables and that sort of thing
a lot of times the internal um mechanism
isn't mature enough
to actually surface that but they don't
understand the risk right so i think
that's a challenge and i know that's not
the question that your answer that
you're asking me but i just i wanted to
point that out that
um so i don't disagree with what you're
saying
but i i honestly think it's just a messy
process we're gonna have to get through
so yes some people might get in trouble
and sued
because they knew that there was a
problem with the way that they were
distributing something online or
interacting online or permissions or
privacy or how they were handling their
data
or when they'll get sued out of business
that's gonna happen but it's not gonna
be everybody
and people will learn from that
particular case i sort of sound like a
horrible hard ass but they'll learn from
that case and things will improve
but that's the process of climbing up
that hill to like
standardize normalized behavior and so
to the extent you know i think that
might have a little bit to do with the
culture of the business how transparent
do you want to be
how much does society value that
transparency
am i going to be afraid to use something
if nothing's safe
am i going to use the product that says
they're not safe or am i going to be
use the one that doesn't say anything
that depends on whether or not i know
it's safe or not so i think we're just
in this kind of mismatch of
stuff but i i argue um
some from research and some from
intuition i won't pretend that my
research has been
as rigorous as it will be two years from
now but that
we're gonna get there and we're gonna
push through um to the other side
and and yes i agree it is a disincentive
to surface those types of things but i
don't really think that's what's going
on
i don't think i i think they don't know
i think they have i think they just
haven't they're not paying attention
that's my experience
you go in you say stuff and they're like
oh wow i hadn't thought of that
like like just some of the smartest
people in the world they just hadn't put
their mind
to it and so my argument is put your
mind to it earlier
and i think that's the advantage if you
put your mind to it earlier then you can
mitigate that through architectural
concerns and also just through
communications
is that helpful at all yeah
partly i mean do you think there are
legal or policy reforms that could
address this that's a good question
um yes
i do think so but i think we'll end up
in that particular argument of like how
open and free do we want to allow these
technologies to be
um versus safety so i think we're gonna
i think we're gonna get a little bit of
both um
the interesting aspect to what you're
asking that's kind of making me tilt my
head and be silent
is the global nature of the internet and
web right so if you ask me about that in
the u.s
very capitalist-centered u.s i would say
yeah you know there's a certain set of
legislation that might be
put in place that can leave things more
open or
free organizations from litigation or
you know
have them be less at risk for litigation
based on the types of behaviors that you
were deciding
but it's not that it's global right and
so
i'm not really sure i'm not really sure
how that would might work out at a
global level
if that makes if that makes sense that's
something to think about
you